this week on brian ross investigates the
apostle the leader of a church that
claims millions of devoted followers
around the world set to go on trial this
year charges of rape and the sex
trafficking of young girls from his own
congregation
parishioners adult women
turn up lined up because he's the
apostle
and the aposos handmaid who allegedly
helped to recruit the girls ready now to
testify against him
we'll get the inside word on what she's
prepared to reveal about the man who
says he is christ on earth
plus covet confusion why can't the top
health experts in the bible
administration get their facts straight
the american medical association harshly
rebuking the cdc this week saying the
guidelines are confusing and
counterproductive and risk spreading the
virus even further
even a supreme court justice seemed to
get it wrong we have over a hundred
thousand children
which we've never had before in
serious condition
and
many on ventilators dr william shafter
is here to help us sort it all out
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
why is it that you think that the vast
majority of your allies in the united
states senate are not standing behind
you we did have that statement by mike
rounds because mitch mcconnell is a
loser
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin tonight with the man
called the apostle the leader of a
worldwide church who if some have
likened to the late millionaire
pedophile jeffrey epstein both had money
and power and face charges of
trafficking young girls for their
apparently insatiable sexual appetites
rhonda
that's right brian in the case of the
so-called apostle nayson joaquin garcia
he's pleaded not guilty to a range of
charges brought by the california
attorney general and remains the leader
of his church which has not opened its
own investigation and is sticking by a
man accused of a long list of horrible
crimes
the man whose followers called him the
apostle hasn't been in one of his
churches for more than two and a half
years now
since june of 2019 nasa and joaquin
garcia has been awaiting trial in a los
angeles county jail facing 23 counts of
rape sexual abuse and the trafficking of
minors all allegedly involving young
girls from his church
he is a sexual deviant predator
this man is a predator
parishioners adult women
turn a blind eye because he's the
apostle
everything he does and anything you do
to him even though it seems wrong it's
going to be forgiven because he
is basically god on earth
that's what they preach
the apostles trial is now set to begin
in the spring of this year as his
defense team works to undercut the
expected testimony of the jane does his
alleged victims
they don't want to talk
about the facts of this case
they don't want to talk about the
statements from five victims
about how they were raped by mr garcia
they don't want to talk about how miss
oaxaca
and miss uh more relevantly obviously
miss ocampo
would bring these girls to him
they don't want to talk about
these women these girls
who have
complained to the attorney general's
office
about being forced to orally copulate mr
garcia
and they don't want to talk about
the statements by the victims your honor
that oral cop was forced on them
they don't want to talk about the videos
with a young boy and mr garcia
having an orgy
the young boy
having sex with a member of his own
family your honor
they don't want to talk about that
because those facts are not good for
them
the apostles defense team has been
arguing that prosecutors help the young
women concoct the story of their abuse
and the lawyers clashed late last year
over efforts to get the phone records of
a former prosecutor amanda plissner
now they just wanted it personal
they knew exactly where this her works
now your honor
but they served her at her home
this was them saying
guess what we know where you live
they did it sneakily and deceitfully
the light of the world church has its
international headquarters in
guadalajara mexico where the apostle
once was treated as christ on earth but
now authorities in mexico have opened
their own investigation into the alleged
sex crimes and his lawyers want to know
the context they may have made with the
former california prosecutors they're
also trying to intimidate mexican
prosecutors
they know full well that those people
could be in danger but they do it anyway
it got emotional this is a very personal
to me
but that the defense opposition be
sealed
because it does mean uh mexican
prosecutors several of them
and
that should not be allowed in the public
domain it also slanders ms prisoner and
that should not allow it to be in the
public domain thank
lead defense lawyer alan jackson denied
any wrongdoing
we are not seeking to harass anyone
and nothing we did
nothing we did was illegal and they have
demanded to have the phones and real
names of the jane does the alleged young
victims i think it's important for the
court to understand the volume of
information we got on the journalist
phones if you
search all of jane joe two's
communications
the first time she ever mentions the
word reign ever
in any context that we've been able to
find
is when she
and another individual
are concocting a story to make up
a false written allegation so that she
can win her boyfriend's affections back
that
is what miss fusco and the hg has
suggested well there's nothing to see
here
that's not relevant material
not only is it relevant material it's
great
but in addition to the so-called jane
does the prosecution is counting heavily
on one of the women who was initially
arrested with the apostle as his
recruiter alondra ocampo who has now cut
a deal with the government and will
testify against him at trial and then be
sentenced later
october 12 2022 your honor and this is
pursuant to an agreement that we had
with the people
that agree with you
and we're joined now by the lawyer from
this ocappa fred thea garaga mr thea
garaja what is your client prepared to
say about the apostle
yes brian thank you for having me uh
miss ocampo is prepared to testify uh
about
uh
this entire
human trafficking ring that uh that the
apostle was
uh
directed her to recruit uh young girls
uh for his sexual pleasure
and she stands by her story no change of
plans
no not at all she's been
committed
to this course of action um
she actually was
uh committed to this course of action
even um
or contemplating this course of action
long before a plea deal was struck
but certainly um is committed to this
course of action now
and she faced a serious time behind bars
what sort of a deal has she cut in
negotiations that you've had with the
prosecutors
well she's pledged she was facing
numerous accounts
of uh you know a variety of different
types of uh sexual crimes similar to
what
uh garcia faces now
um however she ended up pleading guilty
to i believe four felonies
um and she will be sentenced on october
12th of this year
and um
uh we anticipate that she will be
released from custody at that point in
time
serving approximately
four years
uh the power of this church is well
known has she faced any pressure on her
or her family not to testify
yes
um she
but most of that
so i'd like to kind of break it up
prior to uh a plea bargain uh she has
been visited
uh she in fact part of my representation
of her she was visited by a member of
the church
who didn't make overt threats but you
know heavily pressured her to
sort of stick to the party line
um and then in terms of her family
you know
part of this uh process by which she is
going to be testifying against the
church has estranged
you know her family from her they
they believe that she is
lying um or that she is now sort of
doing the devil's work because her
family is still firmly entrenched within
the church her her parents her siblings
and especially her parents
and so
um
it's indirect pressure but you know
she's
losing or you know the connection
between her parents is being jeopardized
by the stance that she's taking
in terms of testifying against the
apostle
but she is steadfast in her decision to
testify despite that sort of indirect
pressure you call
yes and by the way by the way this sort
of this indirect pressure and then she's
also aware
that the
that um
the apostle and his family and his
organization
have you know have threatened you know
people in the past who who've gone
against them so she is aware
of the power of this you know so-called
church and the apostle and knows
that
there can be you know
serious sometimes dangerous consequences
for opposing them but yes she is
remaining steadfast in her decision to
testify against the apostle all right
fred theatre garage thank you so much
for joining us tonight keep us posted on
developments
thank you brian
coming up next coveted confusion dr
william shaffner standing by to help us
sort out fact from fiction you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
back as the omicron variant of covet 19
races through the country the world like
wildfire it's become a time of massive
coveted confusion changing often
contradictory advice about what to do
and just how bad it is even supreme
court justice sotomayor got her facts
wrong during oral arguments over the
biden administration vaccine mandate for
companies
so there's no one better to help us sort
it all out than dr william shafner of
the vanderbilt university school of
medicine and advisor to the cdc and
truly one of the country's leading
experts on the disease dr schaffner
thank you so much for being back here
with us you've seen the criticism from
both sides of the aisle from other
scientific experts what's going on
well it's a time of change isn't it and
so recommendations are changing they've
not been communicated really very
effectively and actually we've heard
just over the weekend that they may
change again
particularly recommendations concerning
masking so i think we ought to keep our
seat belts tight and try to listen very
carefully to what the last set of
recommendations are and of course we're
in a circumstance where we have this
variant omicron
brian that's just spreading like
wildfire as you say
across the country
fortunately our vaccines are still
working in the sense that they're
keeping people out of the hospital
still the majority of people who are
hospitalized for covert related illness
are
my unvaccinated friends and neighbors
i'm afraid but if you're vaccinated and
you've had your booster you can get
infected with omicron but you're likely
to have a bad cold or something akin to
that you won't have to go into the
hospital dr schachter we've all sort of
had to become amateur
as we sort out what is happening give us
a reality check about how serious we
should take this and is it as bad as it
we thought it might be or as good as we
thought it might be
well
even we professional epidemiologists
have been uh humbled by covid you know
i've been humble twice i thought things
were going nicely downhill we were
seeing the beginning of the end and
along came delta and when we seemed to
be getting ahead of delta along came
omicron but what i will say is
with some luck if there's not another
new variant creeping up on us
if that happens i would hope that by
february mid-february
omicron might have run its course
throughout the united states and perhaps
we can begin to transition from pandemic
phase to endemic phase
in other words struggling with covid as
a problem perhaps akin to influenza
going forward
dr schaffner a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
there's probably no group that's more
confused or angry than the parents of
school children half the schools are
open half the schools are closed some
students on zoom mass tests
what should be the policy going forward
do you think for putting kids in school
well if i were giving advice
rhonda what i would say first
every parent with a school child should
be vaccinated number two every adult
associated with that school from
custodian cafeteria workers teachers
school bus drivers coaches everyone
should be vaccinated and then every
child age five and older they're all
eligible for vaccine
if all those children and adults were
vaccinated schools would be remarkably
safe
and then if you add other layers of
protection such as better ventilation
social distancing wearing the masks wow
every school in the country
could open up at very very low risk
should they all be open now dr schaffner
well it depends on what has been done
regarding the local planning and i get
the sense that some schools have done a
lot of planning others have done not so
much they're more laissez-faire
i'm more worried about the latter
because they could be locations where
this virus is transmitted in the school
environment
if you've done all those good things
then i think those schools certainly
should be open and we ought to do
everything we can to make schools
available to our children we know it's
not the best not just for their learning
but for their socialization some
children get hot meals at school
we need to have kids in school
and finally let me ask you very quickly
are we all gonna get it ultimately
uh ultimately i think this omicron
variant will hit us all whether lightly
on the shoulder if we've been vaccinated
and boosted or more seriously if we're
vaccinated
if we're unvaccinated excuse me and when
that happens and it could happen i think
by the end of the month or in mid by
mid-february
then things will start turning down and
as i said we can move from pandemic to
endemic planning
dr william schaffner as always thank you
so much for being with us here tonight
always a pleasure
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see what you say about the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aidan
we begin with your chosen winner npr
reporter steve inskeep who after years
of trying got donald trump on the phone
only to have him hang up leninski
pressed the former president on his
false claims of a rigged election
if i can just move on to ask are you
telling republicans in 2022 that they
must press your case on the past
election in order to get your
endorsement is that an absolute they're
going to do whatever they want to do
whatever they have to do they're going
to do
the only way it's not going to happen
again
is you have to solve the problem of the
presidential rigged election of 2020 mr
president
one more question i want to ask about a
court hearing yesterday on january 6th
judge amit mehta he's gone okay
yep dial tone well there you have it uh
steven gave it a good try
that's right so that's uh the co-host of
npr's morning edition uh he said that he
has tried for six years to get an
interview with donald trump and former
president finally agreed to one this
week uh it lasted just nine minutes
according to npr
and released uh this morning they
released the full audio of it i think
the short length of the interview is a
testament to steve's great skills as an
interrogator he talked to trump about uh
the teen pandemic uh you saw in that
clip there what caused trump to hang up
the phone uh was the stolen election
claims which uh inskeep actually really
pressed him on um and didn't let him
move on from them he had a series of
fact checks of claims that trump uh put
forward and it was a pretty brilliant
interview and honestly the way that any
journalist
should treat a conversation with trump i
think if you're not getting trump to
hang up on you because you relentlessly
grill him on his stolen election claims
uh from the last election you're not
really doing your job um so kudos to
stevens keep their uh for uh you know
getting a nine minute interview after
six years but i think it was worth that
one
absolutely uh fewer kudos for abc and
good morning america for the editing of
an interview with the head of the cdc
let's take a look at what was broadcast
i want to ask you about those
encouraging headlines that we're talking
about this morning this new study
showing just how well vaccines are
working to prevent severe illness given
that is it time to start rethinking how
we're living with this virus that it's
potentially here to stay the
overwhelming number of deaths over 75
percent occurred in people who had at
least four comorbidities so really these
are people who were unwell to begin with
so she went on to say 75 percent of
those who died were had
comorbidity but that really took her out
of context didn't it
right rochelle wensley the cdc director
said that 75 of covid cases of the death
that we've seen from kovid were involved
four or more comorbidities so it meant
that they were seriously ill now many on
the right took that to mean that the
official covet death toll that we have
in america is seriously inflated
um of course what rochelle willinski
actually said was that in a particular
uh
trial and study
of cova deaths among the vaccinated 75
were seriously ill so she was making a
point that the vaccines are actually
working incredibly well not that the
total cova deaths that we've seen in
america are inflated by you know 75
percent so a terrible job of editing abc
really bad job of editing and abc news
has been caught doing this before where
they've edited something to make it
shorter and have ended up removing
necessary context from an interview so
they've run into this problem before and
uh they certainly got a lot of criticism
for it this week they absolutely did and
they deserve to be called a loser for
that aidan mclaughlin thank you so much
for being with us and that is our
program for tonight
thanks for joining us and thanks to our
team here at law and crime as we begin
the third year of our program brian ross
investigates we'll see you again next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you